une réunion détendue autour d'un thé et
mais une réunion pour discuter d'un
thème délicat le surpoids et l'obésité
chez les plus jeunes la maison des
parents de trappes propose aux enfants
et à leurs parents un programme de cinq
séances jusqu'au mois de décembre le
principe c'est leur parler d'équilibré
alimentaire de leur apprendre à manger
de façon équilibrée tout en gardant le
plaisir donc on aborde diverses
thématiques théorique mais aussi
pratique puisqu'il ya deux ateliers
dédiés à la cuisine l'un est dédié à la
préparation d'un petit déjeuner goûter
et l'autre est dédié à la préparation
d'un repas équilibré un repas équilibré
justement qu'est ce que c'est il doit se
constituer d'un produit laitier d'une
céréales de fruits de légumes et d'un
apport protidique apportées par les
oeufs le poisson ou la viande des
notions que l'on doit très souvent
répété pour qu'elle soit entendu car la
cause et de santé publique attrape par
exemple 20 % des enfants sont en
surpoids et en obésité et il est
important d'intervenir le plus tôt
possible dans la vie du jeune on parlera
pas de régime alimentaire dans ce cas là
mais simplement pour l'enfant le en bas
âge c'est contrôler la quantité de sucre
les bonbons les viennoiseries et les
sucreries qu'on lui donne et puis des
petits les inciter à bouger car un repas
équilibré ne se résume pas seulement à
ceux qui se trouvent dans l'assiette il
est aussi essentiel dans l'enfance de
pratiquer une activité sportive
la prochaine rencontre aura lieu le 6
octobre au matin les suivantes ses
talons jusqu'au 9 décembre